dos cosas muy importantes
siempre nos dijeron muchos pobres sueños
más
sí
vemos cosas para las personas del día y
entonces galones de agua aceite los
pasas para entonces y nos tomamos
incendiaria y mucha gracia
despliegue un aproximadamente cinco
horas después de estas cinco
presentaciones
recuerdo que nos bajaron de una
camioneta a otro lugar
dos horas después se bajaron todavía
tenemos que caminar a la comunidad en la
que veníamos de quedadas terminamos
aproximadamente una hora en esa hora
están las cosas y la humanidad
la mochila imagina en la vida mientras
la empresa va en contra de la ciudad
y nada más
y
tiene dos caras
[Música]
yo veo a múltiples comunidades indígenas
y las personas indígenas
entonces vamos
y webó
se alimentó con ustedes
[Música]
las comunidades están llenas de mujeres
para trabajar con nosotros
es un día muy aparte nosotros comíamos
finalización anticipada
así que terminábamos sobre la comunidad
con ellas que empezaban primeras las
chicas y si cada navidad las más grandes
en el cual sus hermanos más grande
aproximan teníamos
quienes asesoraron porque eran
destructores prestados
a 500 mil pesos
tales
a 100 años
es impresionante
a sus familias
y religiosos católicos cristianos
[Música]
mujeres
ahí es cuando te das cuenta que ellas a
pesar de las circunstancias de la
familia
son personas como nosotros tenemos la
indígena
nos estamos obligando a que estas
mujeres estaban acostumbradas siempre
movimientos alteración de sus zonas de
sus esposas de sus hijos ahora ellas en
áreas para buscar a sus hijos chicos con
los ancianos los podemos estar empezando
a hacer cuantas más buscarnos se salgan
pensando a va a ser porque intentan
aprender a hacer palabra nos vemos en
las esquinas con las ganas de vista
impedida pruébalo nosotros les damos
es lograr es en consultarnos es
impresionante
a las personas en general es
ellos pensando que seguir
a veces
josefina iguales semanas del mes sales
de sus abuelas diaria
de verdad espirituales y la
espiritualidad
nosotros deberíamos ser nosotros mismos
para nosotros mismos para después todas
las acciones que tengamos se valga a
otras personas y podemos ayudar a este
sector que relativamente volver a vivir
de ahora la gente porquería solicitadas
han empezado a caer a colectivos para
ser independientes y no necesitar
necesariamente a un hombre versión
varias y que podamos apoyarlos sólo para
lograr fortalecer un sentido y en día
para ellas mejor
y solamente falta que uno despierte
resiste